[Music]
[Music]
hey it's us again
yeah and it's tuesday i know and uh
what well i might have to run out there
and get some more of that tea
[Laughter]
well i'd almost drank it up you have a
lot left what are you talking about no
it's not much i don't want to take this
mostly ice
i got some of that ginger lemon tea that
it made why don't you go make me a drink
too while you're going
so we don't have any alcohol not okay
because it's only early afternoon
i'm [ __ ] up let me go
[Laughter]
that was just water with that black
cherry like flavoring in it
so if there's any of that left but uh
hey hi you guys hope you're having a
good tuesday i like your little space
invader there fourth drawer down
um so yeah we actually got more into
the unsolved mysteries last night than i
thought we would
for some reason i don't know why i
thought this but i was like looking at
all the um
looking at all the uh what's your
columns the uh episodes what's that word
yeah episodes
and i thought that there were more than
there were like for the second thing so
i was just kind of like oh man we only
watched four of them but then when i
looked at the list today i was like oh
no actually we watched five of them and
there's only one left that we haven't
seen yet
so we haven't seen so i figured well
it's like it's kind of like we're
reviewing the whole see
the whole second season because we've
seen like almost all of the episodes
except for
lady the lake is i think the only one
that we haven't watched yet i'm not
really sure
oh yeah i was gonna say that's on my
glass what are you doing
artichoke jar look at this is so classy
i got my [ __ ] lipstick all over the
side of the
glass so gross and like look at this
check it out you guys i was like washing
the coffee pot this morning before i
make coffee
and for some reason like the lip of it
cut my huge gash from my finger
and i was like i was like stumbling
around for um
band-aids and i guess we had like an old
first aid kit like under the sink in the
bathroom and like i just pulled one out
without looking at it and it's this
black panty that says
fail
i was like thanks that's that's a real
like boost to my self-esteem
i don't know we were looking at youtube
yesterday and a couple a couple days
back like two days ago
there's uh some channel on there they
hosted uh jeffrey combs
jeffrey combs is [ __ ] starting to get
into the youtube scene
and that channel that had him on isn't
bigger than ours
yeah so i'm thinking that once we hit
about 10 000 subs we're going to do
something like having maybe jeffrey
comes would be on our show
nice yeah he seemed like a lovely person
yeah
and once i hit that 10 000 subscribers
mark i'm gonna feel better
more like my bigger exia will be
conquered
and i'll start asking some more famous
guests we've had some semi-famous guests
on already it's just that the show
really didn't evolve that way
but i'm thinking maybe we should when it
comes to movies and entertainment
yeah i mean every now and then we can
have someone like i said it's usually
it's kind of a pain in the ass like to
have
guess on but it's like it i could
probably figure it out like yeah and
it'll probably be a bonus show not a
regular show maybe
yeah that's all you know what i mean
like yeah we could just do it like every
now and then
every now and then yeah like
particularly for doing like a movie
review or
you know maybe like a special every
couple whatever yeah you know we can
just like get somebody yeah i think so
or
we've had some paranormal related guests
on you know like
yeah we had the guy from summer wind and
then yeah and then we had uh we've had
angry
pope on a bunch yeah i can get that i
can get that you
that navy pilot who saw the tic tac ufo
he's a good guest i've watched him on a
couple other shows i could get him
fourth row down says i bet bruce
campbell would do it wouldn't that be
awesome
yeah he couldn't have but once you start
getting to that 10
000 subscriber range you become more
attractive i think to some of those
people it's worth their time to come on
your show we're already attracted we're
already good
i mean we some of our shows have 40 000
views on it so i think
actually i think and lorraine had 60 000
on it didn't it
like i said that's by far biggest like
biggest show
even even even our kind of average
run-of-the-mill kind of show now the
ones that are a couple years old
can have five seven five to ten thousand
views on them
yeah which is weird i hardly ever go
back and like um go and look
yeah but i've looked at some of the ones
in the past they're like man it's got 15
000 views [ __ ]
holy crap that's yeah because i'm happy
if we get a thousand
yeah i don't really like expectations
honestly like we just do the show
because
we because we want to and then like i
don't even like i don't even go back and
check them anymore
i mean i go back and check like you know
and answer comments and stuff like that
but it's like other than that i don't
know
over the past couple years it's kind of
grown into
into a pretty big channel some people
thought we'd be you know have a hundred
thousand subs by now but you know what i
mean i think that's a little optimistic
with the
present day algorithms and everything
that they use and suppression and
they don't want to pay you that much
we're not everyone for all you know
also for all i know they lie about how
many views you get
so they don't have to give you a very
big paycheck and we don't you can't
really believe any of the counters
yeah you know you can buy views yeah i
know you can also buy subs
well yeah you can do something like
everything every platform that means the
platforms can lie to you and say
and [ __ ] and take subs away or have
shadow amount of
subs or shadow views that way they don't
have to pay you for them
i don't trust them i'm [ __ ] tom ross
i'm talking about tom ross doesn't
[ __ ] trust you
i like when you talk about yourself in
the third place oh yeah i have to go out
of body to discuss it
i'm going out i'm going over here and
going over here i talk about it
to myself yeah tom what do you think
about that yeah exactly goddammit
you want to talk about unsolved
mysteries go ahead and talk about
themselves so while you were in there
with a drink i
told them i said um it actually didn't
occur to me that we had almost finished
like
season two i thought there were two more
episodes but actually we saw all of them
except for one
uh lady in the lake which we'll probably
watch again uh watch tonight i don't
know we might talk about it on matinee
tomorrow but i might do another movie as
well
so we can uh generally kind of like talk
about the whole
season about which ones we like the most
now the ones i don't think we watched
them in the right order
because i was like looking at another
person's like review of them and i was
like
that's not the order that we watch them
in so i don't know if like netflix just
put them in a different order
down had a [ __ ] brilliant statement
tom's butt
describes it discusses it with his own
butt
and he's trying to say i get chuck
tingle with myself
it's true that's it is true yeah and it
is true
exactly and your butt definitely does
discuss some stuff
yeah it can discuss [ __ ] and drive other
people out of the [ __ ] room
just you guys know what i'm talking
about
the [ __ ] that [ __ ] florida skunk
[Laughter]
that ain't no [ __ ] myth that's right
he's out there
he's in one of these days one of these
days i'm gonna make that fake video of
our new camera's coming tomorrow so it's
like maybe we can make that video
finally one day they're gonna catch him
and then i have to let it go because
they're just like that
we don't want any part of this skunk
it was right there in the name i don't
know why we didn't like see that coming
but that's well that's funny because now
next time like um
next time you're in the room and you
kind of like uh
and you kind of let what i'm gonna be
like what are you discussing over there
i gotta get out of there
you see look man they're saying the
number of subs don't mean much
uh [ __ ] graham townsend saying
youtube's been lying for years
uh mark said he's seen channels grow to
a million subs in a week with no with
that no added views
there's all kinds of [ __ ] you know
all kinds of shenanigans
i'm just saying big mannequins big tech
is about shenanigans
they're all about shenanigans
i'm just going to say shenanigans i'm
going to say it like that
that is what it's like shenanigans it
sounds like a bad indie band
yeah it's like the shenanigans that's
the michigan version where's sophie
she's in there
[Laughter]
it's all shenanigans
[Laughter]
and chicanery chicanery and tomfoolery
yeah yeah yeah
all right go ahead yeah [ __ ] up the
show
you're [ __ ] on the show [ __ ] up
the show yeah uh so
like i said so i'm kind of going in the
order not necessarily the order that we
watch them we're just kind of like going
all over the place like
in the order that the notes that this
other person wrote out about
so one of them okay so let's talk about
the one
that's called the washington insider
murder
now can i just say like right from the
outset
is that a dog barking outside no it's
the neighbor's kids out there playing in
the backyard that scared me i was like
what the [ __ ] my name is like what the
hell is this
child like voices i says [ __ ] is this
place haunted again
childlike [ __ ] voices we're talking
about unsolved mysteries all of a sudden
we're here
yeah yeah yeah like little kids so it's
a little
they have neighbors next door yeah and
there's a window right there and they
have like a pool that's like
a little pool this might be like 20 feet
yeah we can hear their dog and we can
hear their kid out there yelling yeah
but yeah so there's one called
washington insider murder
now can i just say this is about uh jack
wheeler
and he used to work uh he was a white
house aide he worked under several uh
administrations i think he
came in under reagan maybe and i think
he worked under bush and stuff too
now they actually found his body in
a landfill in 2010.
so presumably he had been murdered so of
course because he was a white house aide
and i think he had worked for like
a defense contractor right he was like
in cyber security or something yeah so
some people thought there was like some
kind of conspiracy and stuff so they
kind of like
i thought it was good because they kind
of presented some of that but then they
kind of like presented kind of the other
side you because i'm gonna say
like i don't know i'm not a cop i'm not
an investigator or anything like that
i'm just somebody that's into true crime
and like reads a lot of true crime
i'm saying i don't i'm not even sure
that this dude was murdered
i think i don't think he was what
happened well because okay so they found
his body in the landfill which means
which says to me well his body ended up
in a dumpster somewhere and then i got
taken to the dump obviously
it was in a dumpster but it wasn't
robbed it had had all of his stuff on
him
yeah he had like money and he had like a
really expensive
ring like yeah and stuff like that and
the way he died was blunt force trauma
and i said you know
that could have come from not
necessarily being beaten to death which
is what they said
but i mean he could have fallen into the
back of the truck
or maybe like the truck kind of smushed
him a little bit well you see when that
when that truck picks up the dumpster it
does this and lifts it overhead and
there's
[ __ ] [ __ ] rattling and the [ __ ]
metal door is opening and it drops you
into the back of the truck and it might
have dropped him on something metal
yeah that's what i mean he was crushed
by stuff that fell on him i think i
don't i think he fell asleep in a
dumpster
and it happened because dude was [ __ ]
they got him on video they tried to
[ __ ] track him around because the fbi
was in on it all the [ __ ] government
agencies trying to figure out what
happened to this guy because he was
he was a hero he's kind of well-known
yeah yeah government
he was running around like he was
running from something but he was
limping and he was like walking around
with one shoe in his hands
there's obviously something wrong with
it it was some elisa lamb [ __ ] like that
they had like before
i think he had some kind of a brain
hemorrhage and he was bleeding on the
brain
i mean he had bipolar disorder so i feel
like maybe he had like some kind of
issue with his meds maybe he forgot to
take them maybe
or maybe like you said maybe he just had
some kind of other event
he had he had bipolar disorder meds may
have had something to do with it but
i don't think it was just that yeah oh i
don't either
i think he had i think he had some kind
of a brand aneurysm
and um like in certain centers of his
brain started to get starved of oxygen
and blood and it
and it made an accident and made him act
[ __ ] weird because he was acting
weird like
a lot of the i think he went into a tom
clancy novel were spies where he thought
spies were after him
because he thought his briefcase was
stolen but he left his briefcase
um so he's not his memories getting all
[ __ ] up
and uh he went tom clancy he had to hide
from the spies and [ __ ] and it was cold
out so he's [ __ ]
got into the dumpster yeah he had a
house yeah but he ran from his house
there was some kind of disturbance there
he had spices all thrown around
they found a footprint looked like a
bigfoot footprint
[ __ ] flat-footed as a [ __ ]
going through maybe yeah maybe
they never did look like sasquatch but
they never did that may have been his
footprint but they didn't say whose it
was
yeah well they never did determine well
because that's the thing there i think
it was his footprint they thought it was
a murder because they're like okay there
was some weird [ __ ] that happened like
before they found his body right like
they like the house across the street or
i don't even think the house was
finished i think they were just building
it
and there was like a smoke bomb set off
over there right and then like they
found
his cell phone like over there by the
smoke bombs they thought that was weird
then his house had gotten broken into so
they said
it looked like but it didn't look like
anybody was rummaging through the place
like looking for valuables it looked
like somebody was just in the kitchen
throwing a bunch of [ __ ] around yeah
i i i have a different idea what
happened
he started to go crazy because i think
yeah he did all that
is i think it was some kind of a brain
hemorrhage
his brain started to malfunction he went
into tom clancy mode he thought [ __ ]
soviet spies were after the deep state
was after him or some [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] like that he's setting off smoke
bombs so he can escape you know under
the cover of smoke and
he's he's not in good shape at this time
he's an older dude
uh his health must have not have been
very good
uh they didn't really get into that but
you look at him he's he's pretty out of
shape
and he's an older guy yeah yeah he was
mid-60s i think
at the time i think it was just a brain
hemorrhage but he's reliving his [ __ ]
glory days you know in a certain way
he's
now a spy and tom clancy novel yeah and
he was like getting in cabs and like
going places where he didn't have any
business going
like there or nobody could think of any
reason why he was you know he was in the
[ __ ]
escape and evasion mode you know that's
what that's that's what happened
and then i think i mean it's sad because
i think that what happened to him was i
think it was because it was real cold it
was like new year's eve or something
um in [ __ ] uh wherever it was
in his mind he's delaware was delaware
in his mind he's evading enemy agents
yeah that's what he's doing but i think
he just got like had a friend that it
was cold and he just climbed into a
dumpster to sleep
yeah i mean because they even talked to
the guy that like found the body like
the guy that worked at the dump that
drove the truck
and he's like it happens every now and
then like you you know homeless people
and stuff like that when it's cold
you go in there to get warm what else
are you gonna do i saw it and that's a
place you know where if you were you
know
freaking we sleep outside in the army
all the time and i looked in that
dumpster but yeah it'd be a good place
to sleep
well yeah it's totally enclosed it
wasn't a dumpster that had food
garbage in it it was a dumpster that had
paper products in it yeah it just looked
like cardboard and [ __ ] like that
cardboard boxes and stuff it was
a dumpster out behind like a warehouse
yeah so it wasn't
a dirty dumpster yeah you know it's not
like it had food and garbage and [ __ ] in
it it was just
cardboard boxes and paper so it would
have been a good place to sleep
stay warm yeah plastic bags and stuff
and i think he just crawled in there to
hide from the enemy agents you know
and get warm and get warm yeah and then
he fell asleep and it fell asleep in
there and it came and threw his ass out
because like i said the dude from the
dump said that he's like that happened
sometimes we put the [ __ ] thing in
the truck and then like somebody pops up
and it's like oh [ __ ] i'm in here you
know what i mean i think he got killed
when it when it started to dump it into
the back he fell out
and [ __ ] you know fell on something
well the doors start swinging and
banging and that thing hit him in the
head probably and killed him
i kind of suspect that's what happened
so i don't really think even though
you know like he i think he was dead by
the time he actually got into the into
the garbage truck yeah
i mean i you know i don't know but i
kind of feel like that wasn't even a
murder
but it's still an unsolved mystery
because they don't know if it was a
murder or if he just like died some
other way
a lot of guys have just had some kind of
brain problem and wandered off and
become homeless people were never seen
again
that's actually that's happened that's
what would have happened with him yeah
and not been killed
yeah i mean he would have froze to death
as a bomb and they were like who the
hell is this dude we don't know
yeah well like i said it's sad it
happens but it's like if you
you know you don't know um so another
one that we watched actually this one
was the first one that we watched it's
called stolen kids
this one was really [ __ ] up sad
oh my god so this happened in 1989
in new york city and there was this
woman and
um she was uh playing with her little
kid
at the park and i guess she like turned
her back for a second or she like
one of the other family members was like
watching the kid and they were going to
go to the store and get the kids some
snacks
and then they came back and they
couldn't find the kid and it was like a
little this was a toddler
like a little boy he was i think he was
two the first one
and then so then three months later a 19
month old little boy
went missing from the same exact park so
they have these two kids moms on there
and it's just like [ __ ] heartbreaking
like
because it's been such a long time i
mean that was 1989 yeah
but the only thing that i can say
because and you said this and then they
had the people um
and it came on then they came on and
were talking about it too they said they
call it when i'm watching this [ __ ] i
call it
that's all about that this is what
happened and then they then they bring
on the
experts and then they confirm what i
said i mean i'm not saying
it's it's not unheard of for
say pedophiles to kidnap children that
young
it's unlikely but it's unusual um so
what they basically said in the you know
the experts said this like you said this
they said you know the fact that they
were little boys and they were that
little they were like toddler age
that suggests someone like a woman that
couldn't have children of her own
um much like you know some women will
steal a baby from a hospital or
something like that if they've just had
like a miscarriage or something if that
does happen
so in a way that's like that's messed up
but i kind of hope
like that that's what happened because
that means that someone raised them
yeah back in those days some of the
people in the area you know they were
saying
somebody's stealing the kids and selling
them not very
unlikely okay because um
if you're usually if a kid is [ __ ]
stolen to sell it's a white kid
yeah because there's lots sadly that's
true it's just true that's what i said
too
it's a much easier it's really easy to
if you need a kid if you want a kid
it's easy to adopt a black child there's
there's a lot of them in the uh
orphanages in the system yeah in the
system so
they're when they sell a kid it's
usually
a [ __ ] wealthy white family
want to buy a child that they raise as
their own
and they're going to claim it as their
own so it has to look like them
yeah so that's what that's why they're
doing it uh
i'm telling you the demographics age and
the race of the child it's a black
female
that couldn't have children and was
taking other people's children
and she probably wanted more than one so
she got two yeah because it was three
months in between
i think that there's a [ __ ] super
super likely
both those kids are alive they're
they're grown people
and that's what i said i really hope so
because they had like i said they had
both the moms on there talking it was
just like heartbreaking
and they didn't know what like happened
to them at least it's better than having
them killed though
yeah that's what i'm saying i really
really hope that that's what happened
yeah i don't think they were killed i
think they were they were raised by
somebody who
a lonely woman lonely black woman and
because they did actually kind of
mention
another case on there where a woman who
had just i think she had just had a
miscarriage or
something like that or she lost her own
child and um
she actually went into a hospital and
stole a baby and they actually did find
that
that person like that baby later on like
when she was grown up and they actually
did like reunite her with her family
so they're kind of hoping that that's
the situation here
but it's been like 30 something years at
this point so they're just kind of
hoping they have gabe good description
they did like a really good age
progression
so they were like you know they were
trying to find this this person
these two uh little boys that were taken
back in 1989
yeah um so then there was one now this
one was really weird
this is probably my favorite one just
because this was like so [ __ ] weird
um a death in oslo now this one yeah
this is a good one
this one was very this one had me
wondering this one is very similar to
the isdahl woman yes like from the 1940s
soon as they talked about the damn tags
the the clothing table yeah just like
this woman
yeah and like summerton man you're right
and just like special forces that's some
spy [ __ ]
back in the time when i was in service
all your sf
guys wore sanitized uniforms
when they went on a mission not when
they were just walking you know just
doing
you never could tell if they were going
to be in uniform or not when they did a
mission sometimes they would just dress
like civilian mercenaries
but one of the things that they did is
even if they had military uniforms on
there's no name tapes
no name tags nothing all removed
it's not to say that they weren't trying
to hide the fact they were special
forces what it was is if they ever got
captured you couldn't tell who was in
charge and who was who
yeah they'd all start lying about who
was who
you know they'd all start claiming to be
the captain or they all started claiming
to be
you know what i mean in charge of the
unit because they already had
pre-planned lies
yeah and to confuse interrogation they
would all claim to be the [ __ ]
unit commander right yeah i mean so they
couldn't figure it out
well the same intel agencies would kind
of do the same thing
cut all the tags out of your clothes so
you couldn't tell these people had been
yeah you couldn't tell where the clothes
came from you couldn't like identify
like what country they were
well what country the clothes were or
what countries they had moved through
yeah so you know that was but that's
kind of retro i don't think that would
work
nowadays the yeah this actually happened
in the 90s and like i said it's really
weird that i hadn't heard about this
case because this is very very similar
to is doll woman
um not quite as grisly as that one like
we did a show about that one like a
really long time ago i think we talked
about is doll woman and somerton man
like which also i think is spy [ __ ] i
think this is probably spy [ __ ] too
so this happened in the mid 1990s
there's this woman
they later found out they did age on her
right they found out she was like what
24
25 something like that so she was really
like kind of um
you know snappily dressed like woman
very elegant looking
she checks into this into the oslo plaza
hotel
in norway obviously and um she's in
there
she was there for what two or three days
right and they said she didn't really go
because they had the key cards then and
they could tell when she went in the
room they didn't necessarily know when
she came out but they knew when somebody
like used the key card to go in there
yeah so so they're like she spent most
of those
few days in her room but like one day
she was gone for like 20 hours like
before she came back
so then um one day
they actually like the guy went up there
and the
do not disturb thing was on her doorknob
like pretty much the whole time
and so like one of the employees of the
hotel went up there and i guess he like
knocked on the door or something because
there was some problem or whatever
and he heard a gunshot and he flipped
out and iran and got the police and so
there was like a 15-minute gap
so they go in there they find the woman
she's lying on the bed she's totally
dressed she's got her high heels on she
looks like she's going out for
you know she's got all black with her
kind of like everything 90s kind of
freaking dark way of chick really
she did yeah black short hair
she was pretty yeah pretty good yeah
because they did a rick and johnny
actually they showed a picture of her
like dead body too
yeah it kind of touched up her forehead
because she shot herself in the forehead
like that they well at first they
thought that
but i don't know it just seems like it
could be a suicide sure
but they were saying that it's like if
she shot herself
like the gun they found the gun like
this like in her but it
like she used her thumb like to shoot
herself which seems
not impossible but odd and also they
didn't find like any blood on her hand
they didn't find any blood on her
clothes
um anything like that but she'd been
shot one time in the forehead
and then the gun was just kind of left
there and then the room had maybe been
like wiped down and then they went in
her closet and like all her clothes like
we said had all the
tags cut out and then they found out
that when she checked into the hotel
a bunch of anomalies yeah yeah like she
checked in under the name
jennifer fairgate i think was the name
that she checked in under and she'd have
an address and everything
but so they go to the town like uh where
the address was which was in belgium
and they said it was this really small
town it was like less than 5 000 people
now the town really existed but the
address she gave
the street existed but that house number
didn't like that
the house numbers on that street like
stopped before that number and they said
and even like the
phone number she gave was one that would
have been from that town but
nobody in that town had it and they
thought it was weird too because they
said she didn't show any
id like even a passport or anything
to check into the hotel which even in
the mid-1990s i'm pretty sure you had to
show
id to check into it yeah she was somehow
able to check into the hotel
improperly and they accepted it for
whatever reason
whatever reason and they didn't have an
explanation of how she actually got into
the hotel the the hotel management
didn't know
yeah uh which me i it's it's a little
weird there might have been a slightly
an inside job
she was an intelligence agent i kind of
suspect and they talked to a guy that
was like um
yeah that was a norwegian or a swiss
like intelligence agent
yeah and he basically said this looks
like an execution is what this looks
like
and it's like in all the [ __ ] about
where she was like her
the [ __ ] with the clothes the [ __ ] with
the you know address and everything
that looks like intelligent [ __ ] yeah
there were some holes in what they said
though
the norwegian firearms experts didn't
know what they were talking about
they they don't have as much experience
as i have with firearms the way they
characterize [ __ ]
there was a browning high power it was a
1930s
era they knew that but they failed to
mention a bunch of stuff about
sanitization because the numbers had
[ __ ] were ground off in a certain
area that was something
when you and certain european
manufacturers are [ __ ] the browning
high power
certain serial numbers were on the
[ __ ] barrel near the chamber
you could see it through the closed
ejection port as as the [ __ ]
barrel as the slide was in battery okay
yeah of course you could ground those
down but there's a bunch of you can drop
acid on there and [ __ ] the numbers
will come right back because when you
punch
numbers into a barrel or into any piece
of metal
the punching action actually causes
molecular density
you know what i mean the molecules bunch
up right there and if you drop
acid on there those bunched up molecules
will dissolve at a different rate from
the other molecules that weren't
bunched up and the numbers will show
they failed to mention that
maybe they thought that maybe they
didn't want they thought that
they would some okay maybe they didn't
want to give away a forensic trick
that you can do because they think that
that helps
them trace weapons but it doesn't help
you trace weapons
you could have every [ __ ] number on a
[ __ ] pistol and
you could find out maybe who originally
purchased it
when it was first sold back in the 1930s
that person's long dead
you'll never be able to legally prove a
chain of custody
those numbers are a waste of time all
right so whoever ground the numbers off
was wasting their time too you might as
well just let them see the numbers
and they were saying about how powerful
nine millimeter was
nine millimeter is not powerful it's
it's a mid mid-range cartridge 44
magnum is a powerful pistol cartridge
they said it was impossible
to shoot yourself in the forehead using
your thumb and still have it well they
didn't say it was impossible
they just said it was unlikely it's a
lie it's a lie if you
turn a pistol around backwards in your
hand stick your thumb through the
[ __ ] trigger guard
and you have one hand and then the other
hand support and shoot yourself in the
forehead
which would be that's how you would
train a [ __ ] intelligent
operative to commit suicide because
through the side of the head you could
actually miss and it can blow your
eyeballs out the [ __ ] because your
eyes are actually below your brain
casing
it's hard and it's also to shoot
yourself through the roof of the mouth
you can get the angle wrong it'll blow
the top of your face off and you'd be
and you'd still be alive
directly into the forehead is a good way
to do it
and the recoil will be absorbed by the
handle your
your thumb will get snagged up in the
trigger guard the hand will fall and the
pistol will still be in your hand
the recoil they made it sound like the
recoil is excessive in nine millimeters
not
it's about like 38 it's mild very very
mild
so it's it's not punishing on especially
on two hands
it's just certain things that they said
i do believe that she was an operative
but i think she was east german well
they figured that out because they did
like a dna analysis
they figured out she was probably about
24 years old they have a really good
sketch of her face they have pictures of
her face
they think she was probably east germany
here's the weird thing
east germany was gone and what 91 yeah
which means that she was out there in
the field for an additional three years
at least
yeah so are they saying the stasi was
still in operation three years after the
fall of eastern germany
maybe maybe stasi and some of the
[ __ ] intelligence agencies of eastern
europe
kind of went rogue after their
government collapsed and maybe they
became a semi-criminal organization
i don't know maybe they started working
for another country
yeah there's no telling maybe they went
to work maybe they were doing contracts
for the cia
who was paying them either way what i
think happened
they hypothesized that she was murdered
by her organization or an enemy
organization i'm gonna say no
she killed herself but they still don't
know i mean the
the mystery was like yeah whether she
was murdered or she killed herself but i
think the bigger mystery was who she was
and
why she was there and who she was
working for i i think most likely
she she was in an intelligence
organization and there was no way out of
that inter
no way out of that organization and she
had done something
over the years that she wasn't happy
with maybe she was suffering depression
and she killed herself
because we don't know who she was or how
she was recruited
for all you know she was you know
basic female intelligence operatives
are basically kind of like high-tech
hookers they sleep with men to get
information
all right and then they sell that
information back
maybe she was recruited out of a [ __ ]
um prison
maybe she was recruited out of an
orphanage at an early age because she
was pretty young she was only
she was only 24. so you don't know
what her life was like she might have
had a bad life and maybe there was no
way out of [ __ ] the intelligence
services
she was then she was and she didn't like
doing it yeah maybe she
[ __ ] up was [ __ ] over these guys
sleeping with guys and [ __ ] them over
and she didn't like doing that maybe she
liked them yeah you know what i mean
you kind of some of that [ __ ] that those
people do man has a
total lack of consciousness you know i
mean it favors psychopaths and
sociopaths
people that can betray people and that's
i think she killed herself because she
didn't like what what she was yeah she
very well might have that's what i think
happened
um i mean you know but like i said i'm
kind of more interested in like why
like you know who she was and what she
was up to
i think she was an east german girl came
out of an orphanage
yeah that's what i think she was
probably brought into the intelligence
like
the femme nikita type [ __ ] that's not
too far out of reality
especially eastern europe yeah type [ __ ]
you know
somebody who's ex expendable and doing
that is a big move up in life for them
you know it's weird too because i mean
like i said the case was kind of similar
to uh is all woman
i think she was the same thing which
also yeah and like that again it was the
same thing where is all women they
weren't really sure if she killed
herself or if somebody else killed her
although in her case i think murder was
a little more
likely because i mean they found like
all those sleeping pills like in her
stomach but they were undigested and
then it
appeared that someone had tried to set
her on fire unless she tried to set
herself on fire which
seems like a shitty way to go especially
since you've already taken a bunch of
is the woman was killed i think so too
i think this one would because that was
like because is doll woman they found
her like way out up in the mountains
like
i've mentioned this before on other
shows
usually a paid assassin makes the murder
look like a suicide
that's the way that's the way and and
you know that's
what certain people in these
intelligence communities are they're
they're assassins well that's why
they're leaving the possibility open on
this case that she could have been
killed by an assassin to make it look
like a suicide
it's possible but i think it's more
likely she killed herself yeah and she
was an intelligence operative
yeah but it's they killed themselves too
yeah maybe she got into a bad gem and
there was nothing no way out
other than that yeah so you know she
might have [ __ ] up
people were coming after her something
like that yeah because you don't know
the situation but like i said i think
that was kind of the most she killed
herself when she heard that
heard the [ __ ] somebody knock at the
door which tells me that she
yes it's like i heard the gunshot
because she'd been there for two or
three days i think at that point she
thought somebody had was coming to get
her that's fine oh you had found her
yeah maybe that's that's probably what
happened
that seems kind of likely yeah she
probably was that oh because like i said
if she was going to kill herself why
didn't she do it before that
i think she i think she thought she had
been compromised yeah and
and i think her own side was after her
not the enemy but her own side
yeah there was no she had nowhere to go
yeah but yeah maybe somebody will figure
it out one of these days
oh no yeah maybe not no
no paperwork no paper trails that's why
they haven't figured out [ __ ] is doll
yeah yeah and that was like back in the
[ __ ] four years what they're doing is
basically what organized
crime does the their uh those units
mimic organized criminals and and use
organized criminals
at that same and pis and bad cops
yeah yeah and then uh let's see what was
the other one the other one was
excuse me the other one was about
[ __ ]
lester eubanks which i had heard of this
case before this actually happened in
1965.
he was a sex offender yeah this guy's a
[ __ ] and he um
back in 1965 this little girl
um she was 14 and she was going to get
some more money for the laundromat like
it was her and her sister or her friend
or something like that were at the
laundromat washing clothes and they ran
out of money so she kind of walked down
the street to get some more money
from her grandma or whatever and this
dude just shot her
and killed and she didn't die outright
which is the most horrible thing and
they kind of like saved that little
tidbit for later and i was just kind of
like oh my god that's like even worse
than [ __ ]
like he shot her and then he um like i
guess he came back and she wasn't dead
so he like [ __ ]
smashed her head with a brick or
something like that it was like [ __ ]
horrible
so they caught the guy like pretty much
immediately because this dude like lived
in the same neighborhood everybody knew
he was like the town weirdo he like kind
of walked down the street with like
[ __ ] nunchucks and all those other
kind of just like thinking he was
[ __ ] bruce lee or whatever
so um and they caught him and he
confessed
and then he got convicted and put on
death row
but then in 1972 ohio abolished the
death penalty and so he
got commuted to a life sentence and then
for whatever reason he was kind of able
to charm his way into this program where
they kind of let some of the inmates
like
like out not not like to run around free
but like with guards like so they'd take
them like on shopping trips and whatnot
like um you know under guard he became a
trustee basically
yeah and um so during one of these
little sojourns where they took them
like christmas shopping he
got the [ __ ] out and escaped and they
have not found him
to this day yeah i think he's dead
though uh he probably would be because
he'd be like oldest [ __ ]
80s i think he's be he'd been his 80s at
this point and somebody with his
uh record because he had already like he
had already been like arrested for like
rape sexual assault and all kind of [ __ ]
like before he even killed this little
girl
so i kind of figured that this is
somebody that
probably once he got out he probably
didn't last too long
yeah i don't think so i mean i hope he
didn't but
they don't know where he went uh after
that and they never they still never did
find out well he didn't have
he couldn't have made a new identity for
himself enough to pass
and get say like health care or housing
so he would have been pretty much
without any kind of [ __ ]
social security support you know what
i'm talking about unless he had somebody
help us
which i kind of suspect that his dad
might have helped him
yeah i think he helped him for a while
but then his dad would have died off
right yeah
all right because his dad would be about
130 now yeah all right
and then any kind of females helping him
they would have
probably you know well he may have they
might have outlived him
it's possible but i don't know
i think he's dead he probably is like i
said it it would be unlikely for him to
have gotten to that age especially as uh
the type of person that he was
there's a chance he could have been
reoffending but probably not i think he
would have gotten
caught as he got older yeah
and i don't think he would have risked
it
maybe not but although like i said i
don't know if he was the type of person
that could
that could just stop doing that he
seemed like angela
true but that's when he was like way
older yeah when he was older by the time
he escaped though
not that much older was he 30 30
something
i think he was in his 30s when he was
maybe but that's yeah
and he did a lot of he was running a lot
of the times from one
woman to the next who was helping him
yeah i don't
he was actually they said he was
actually a pretty charming guy and kind
of like the center of attention
he he wouldn't have been a guy who
couldn't get a girlfriend he could get a
girlfriend well yeah he was a
good-looking dude and he seemed like
you know yeah like i said like a lot of
sociopaths he seemed kind of charming
when he was young he was a serial sex
offender yeah one girl he shot and
killed
yeah yeah yeah that fourteen yeah
you know there's no evidence that he
killed another one but
he might have left that behind him but
that doesn't mean he's had the right to
escape he should have caught him and
[ __ ] brought him back
yeah well yeah he had a life at least
yeah but i think he's dead
prob well let's hope so yeah i'm pretty
sure he's dead and then the last one we
watched like i said we still have to
watch lady in the lake we can watch that
uh tonight sometime but the last one we
watched uh was
the the token supernatural episode yeah
yeah that wasn't that good it was all
right
i didn't yeah i didn't like it yeah it's
tsunami spirits it was kind of all about
it was very unfocused it wasn't really
it wasn't really focused on just like
one case
it was kind of focused on a whole bunch
of different people
who saw weird [ __ ] after that horrible
tsunami that they had back in
with that was 2011 right it was like 20
000 people died
and it's like i think like the most well
written or well structured
the most affecting parts of that i think
were actually just the parts about the
actual tsunami and like the people like
that
one guy like talking about how he found
his [ __ ] dog like
dead daughter like hanging in a tree
yeah and then like they found
his [ __ ] baby like buried underneath
the mud and all that that was like
[ __ ] horrifying
yeah but it's like then they kind of
went off and they were talking about
like all these taxi drivers that said
they were picking up all these like wet
ghosts and like taking them back and
they were taking them like ghost ride
for free and all the other kind of
it's like i hate to be like i guess it
was interesting but like i hate to be
glib
and everything and it's like you know
because everybody there like lost so
many people and that's horrible
so you can see why it would be
comforting you know to say like oh you
know my my dead relative like came to
the door
like you know and they were all wet and
they wanted a towel and ghosts and
everything
one of the things about the accounts
they're very japanese
in their narrative you know what i mean
it's like something comes out of damn
japanese ghost movie
you know that's why japanese ghost
movies are the way they are
so i don't know they had that shinto
priest there was he shinto or buddhist
oh i can't remember now i thought he was
buddhist but he might quote me
yeah maybe i thought he might have been
shinto but uh he could have been
either one doesn't really matter he was
saying that
rational people might say that had to do
with trauma and
visions and psychology and he says but
we don't we don't like we don't talk
about it that way
we just accept it for what it is this is
the experiences that they have
you know the means is you can interpret
it any way you want to interpret it
but if you want to i
you know they're they're just tales to
me
they were interesting stories none of
them were really compelling as
well like i said they were it was so
generalized because it kind of just
bounced around
basically it was just kind of like you
know all these people had like ghost
experiences
in the wake of this horrible tragedy
yeah and it bounced around like you said
that that episode did kind of have edit
problems
yeah like i said it just seemed a little
scatter shot yeah like i understand
that you know everybody liked like the
original unsolved mission
and i will say that i like this season
better because
it has like more it seems like it has
more of a variety you know what i mean
it's like it had one from overseas it
had
actually like a debt like a fugitive one
which we i don't think we had on the
first one
um oh yeah i guess we did that french
guy was kind of a fugitive wasn't he
but they they seem to be like um you
know trying to get like one of each
thing
like that they used to have on unsolved
mysteries except for like they haven't
done like lost treasure or anything like
that yet but because they used to death
in the old one too
but you know so a lot of people liked
the ufo ones and the ghost stories and
stuff so it's like it's cool that they
are giving a nod to that because it's
kind of like you know not to the
original show because they're like they
had paranormal ones and everybody liked
those
but this was like easily my least
favorite of the season
miss jay is asking us how we're doing
how you doing miss jay
we're doing good actually yeah just um
that was the last one that we saw it was
yeah and like i said there's only one
more left
actually i don't think even we got
almost to the end of that one and i was
just like and i got too sleepy and i was
just kind of like
what did we watch that other one you
know and actually it was almost at the
end of that one wasn't it we just never
did finish that one did we no but i
think it only had like five or ten
minutes left
right um because like i said it's kind
of cool like i like ghost story as much
as the next person i was it's i was
telling you last night it kind of
reminded me of
when i was in wales um
and if anybody in the uk you guys
probably know but there was a really
horrible tragedy that happened there in
uh abervan
i can't remember what year it was but
basically like all the coal slurry or
the slag or whatever like slid down the
side of the mountain and like buried a
school
and like um you know killed like a bunch
suffocated a bunch of children
yeah and uh i actually went to the
cemetery there in abravan
and like the more i read about it they
were saying like all these people it's
kind of like 9 11 i guess where like all
these people like before it happened
like sid said that they had all these
nightmares about being suffocated by
like
something black like it was almost kind
of like um
a bunch of people had like a premonition
yeah like
before but so i kind of it kind of
reminded me of that but this
the tsunami one it was kind of like they
didn't really talk about people having
premonitions about it they just talked
about people seeing ghosts like
yeah i don't know if i ever mentioned it
on the show but i had i told jenny i had
a dream
the night before 9 11 happened i had a
dream that i flew
a plane a jet a huge jet plane into
a federal express mail building
huh remember i told you that yeah that's
right yeah i was flying the plane
and i saw a big old big old
complex of buildings and it was the u.s
mail or something and i
flew it into that on purpose
and i don't know why and then i woke up
i woke up
you know i mean before yeah got up out
of bed and goes that was a weird dream
and then a few hours later on the news i
saw that second plane hit that [ __ ]
tower that's pretty weird and what was
weird is that that was mail planes
you know uh when i listed mail planes
or they they thought it might have been
a mayo plane i don't know
you know what's weird about that is that
when i lived in tampa
um somebody flew like like one guy like
flew like one of those single engine
like planes like flew into the side of
the bill i think he was the only one
that got yeah it was a male building
wouldn't it
oh i don't remember i know somebody from
the map from the post office went postal
or something and flew
yeah that might have been the same thing
it was tamper or clear water or
something
or something yeah and i think somehow
that event of that guy crashing it into
i think it was in
into a into a male building i think he
worked for the [ __ ] post office
that made me have that dream where i did
that
yeah but it was weird the timing was
where it is it was weird
just weird yeah there were some other
people that said that they kind of had a
weird
dreams and premonitions of it that yeah
it happened
i mean like i said unless they had like
some [ __ ] unless they wrote it down
before the [ __ ] happened and like had it
[ __ ] notarized and [ __ ] like yeah
that's hard to prove
because it's like easy to say afterwards
but i didn't think anything i'm not
saying you're lying i'm just saying
there's no way
i didn't think anything of it at the
time know what i mean yeah
until i saw the [ __ ] twin towers of
it but waking up i was just like yeah
this is another just another dream just
another weird dream sure yeah
i mean like like all the time
what's funny is that i don't have very
many weird dreams anymore
i had more i had weirder dreams when i
was younger
yeah there's something about as you get
older i think your brain gets more
efficient
and you don't go down these flights of
fancy when you're asleep
or maybe it's just because people get
just boring when they get maybe
nice to have down your imagination just
kind of like gets flabby
[Laughter]
i used to have weird [ __ ] out of body
experiences and
[ __ ] dream true and have waking
dreams where you become conscious in a
dream and then you start controlling the
dream
yeah i used to have all that when i was
younger i used to be able to go to sleep
this was like when i was a teenager i'd
go to sleep and then when i woke up it
was like i had leveled up
yeah all of a sudden i had gained new
abilities or new understandings
it was kind of like as you were sleeping
your body
your mind would process things that were
happening each day
and then somehow you'd have like a
breakthrough and then you'd wake up and
you felt like you were a different
person
with a whole of the whole new
understanding of the world
yeah do you remember that yeah and all
of a sudden you could do something
that you couldn't do before well that's
kind of um what one of the theories is
like
about what dreams are is that they're
your brain like trying to like now that
your consciousness is kind of off and
like stopping
like yelling at you that it's like
sorting [ __ ] out back
yeah yeah there was like a couple there
was like a couple times like in that
10th 11th 12th grade period
where you would like totally like level
up
and you were like in a new state of
consciousness yeah
and you can you know i mean with new
abilities it was weird man
but i guess that's just part of having
weird breakthroughs as you're developing
like an emergent property would come out
yeah i don't know if you guys in the
comment section might know what i'm
talking about and uh someone's asking if
we've seen the alienist i haven't yet
though i did read the book
um so i actually do want to watch that
one of these days because i really
really liked the book a lot i read the
book like um several years ago um
mark said i do my quantum mechanics
homework in my sleep
well that's what i mean that's what
sleep's supposed to do it's supposed to
kind of like
defrag everything in there and kind of
like sort [ __ ] out so when you wake up
you're like aha i got the answer i mean
you know that doesn't always happen but
that's
i think technically that's kind of what
the purpose of it is you know jay says
hormones play a bigger role in dreams
and people realize
just like poltergeist activity can ramp
up yeah
probably right yeah i have yeah i've
read a couple
maybe opening up new neural pathways as
you learn
certain things that gives you that
feeling of rant of
leveling up um and it happens mostly
when you're young
during like you're having those early
big growth spurts yeah
through your teen years and hormones are
happening on top of that
but then i think a bunch of emergent
properties start happening because
you're becoming more conscious
or your consciousness is changing into a
new form then i think eventually what
happens is you get kind of old
and you've kind of stabilized you got
ossified
yeah and you become very efficient at
thinking
so you're not as creative as you were
uh or you tend not to be as creative as
you were
because you don't waste time with
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] yeah
you know like you did when you were when
you were young i could used to look at
[ __ ] when i was younger
and i just [ __ ] have [ __ ] flights
of fancy and [ __ ] embellish it in my
own mind and
you know like listening to music yeah it
was like a [ __ ] intense experience
listen to it now it's just kind of
humdrum but see but
people who like you know who are artists
or writers or something like that that
you have to try
and like maintain that you have to
maintain that right throughout your
adulthood
otherwise you're not going to be i seem
to be able to do it sometimes
you know what i mean like if i really
start cutting up on the show
it's like it's coming back yeah but
left to my own devices i'll just try to
sail through it with minimum [ __ ]
minimum resistance i guess you could say
you know
yeah you know what i mean like yeah yeah
whatever
yeah whatever yeah it's like that i
don't want to be like that
yeah i don't ever want to go stay active
yeah
gotta stay active gotta stay in a
positive mindset well you gotta stay
like mentally active like i said this is
why i treat you know
right because like i said i'm a writer
and you know i like to do creative
things so it's like i don't i don't want
to get into
a thing where it's like let's do it i
don't want to do anything right
that's eventually what happens to a lot
of people not everybody though
but like i said you have people you have
to struggle to like maintain it yeah
sure when you're older a lot of people
were never like you though
that's true i knew i knew guys that were
in their senior year of high school that
were already old men
yeah well oh yeah yeah i did too
you see him later you know you're on
facebook like [ __ ] 30 something years
later you look at he goes damn you know
[ __ ] yeah yeah
he looked like a like a 90 year old man
you know he just
zach says i'm worried i'll lose my
artistic passion when i get older and be
left with nothing
don't well don't think of it like that
though it's like i i never found it all
that difficult to like hang on to it so
maybe you won't either always stay
always try to stay
in um a mode of growth
growth and development and you know i
wasn't always like that there's times
where i have like a
a year that was [ __ ] bad or some
negative years
you have to shake that off and try to
get always trying to do
like new things or things that you enjoy
you know what i mean yeah
like it's just get excited about
something and just stay excited if
you're not excited about this anymore
and find like a new thing to be excited
about yeah for me
you have to have the physical dimension
things have to be physically hard too
you know what i mean if it's just me
just mental is not enough for me
yeah yeah i'd be the kind of guy who
want to take [ __ ] fencing classes or
[ __ ]
you know that kind of [ __ ] that's you
know boxing get back into [ __ ]
mma you know beach and beat some dude's
ass
get your ass you know
i'd be like into that yeah little swole
wanted to come over here and train me
that [ __ ] can throw like [ __ ]
four four [ __ ] little swell could
throw
four blows a second he sounds like a
damn machine gun
[Laughter]
his uh older brother was a [ __ ] bro
as a boxer i think he's pro or semi-pro
boxer
so he grew up being the punching bag and
just getting beat up all the time by his
brothers
and he had two brothers and that little
dude man
look at him you don't look at him you
wouldn't think there's much there that
[ __ ] could knocked out two dudes
in a crowd of people and nobody even
noticed
walked away like nothing happened yeah
because the police station was right
there yeah that's right
yeah he says his writing knocked two
dudes they were big dudes and then just
knocked him out and walked away like he
didn't do nothing
yeah walked away like he didn't do
anything
see that's what he left in their [ __ ]
cup c's on the ground their
feet were smart like that you gotta be
feeling smart like that
and i and i do feel like too that um
you know people who like really wanna
fight and stuff like that i think that
it's
under it's an underrated quality that
it's um really good if you are really
good at getting your ass beat
and you can take a lot of abuse because
a lot of fighting
is how who's gonna get tired out first
so if you can take
a lot of abuse then you will probably go
far in that arena
all right you want to wrap holy crap
we've been going for an hour yeah we got
to go
all right so uh we will probably watch
like the last episode of uh
of uh unsolved mysteries tonight maybe
talk about that tomorrow but i pro will
probably watch a newer movie as well to
talk about tomorrow
as well so uh thanks everybody for
stopping by and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bye